scientists in the 1970s predicted the
collapse of society
ending humanity's current civilization
by 2050 and an updated study says that
up to now the predictions have been spot
on let's have a little peek
into the future fire the past
back in the 1970s a group of number
crunchers from massachusetts institute
of technology also known as mit
produced a study and crunched their
numbers through a system dynamic
simulation model called
world three using empirical data that
was published to the club of rome a
swiss
based global think tank which includes
the usual suspects like um bureaucrats
government officials diplomats
economists and business leaders
can't take that lot anywhere the
scientists published their results in a
best-selling book from 1972 called
limits to growth to forecast potential
global ecological and economic collapse
coming up in the middle of the 21st
century
the variables included fertility rates
population mortality rates industrial
output
services food production persistent
pollution non-renewable resources
ecological footprint and human welfare
however the original study has since
been revisited by sustainability and
dynamic systems analysis published over
at the yao school of environment using
the same world 3 model given the
unappealing prospect of collapse i was
curious to see which scenarios were
aligning most closely with empirical
data today
after all the book that featured this
world model was a bestseller in the 70s
and by now we'd have several decades of
empirical data which would make a
comparison meaningful
and the conclusion from the new study
the unappealing prospect of collapse
but apparently there is hope the new
study concluded that society has about a
decade to change course and avoid
collapse by investing in
wait for it sustainable technologies and
equitable human development
i'll tell you what this climate change
stuff is not
going away
you